[Music]
one day let's mix things up a bit
you're just happy you found your fan
club I've been waiting six years for
your second book is it coming out soon
I'm working on it what do you do for
money then
you married rich
I actually came here looking for
inspiration
you both are so terrifyingly
in this and you're both just so
extraordinary separately so seeing you
two together on screen for me was like
fireworks you're such a dynamic duo
congratulations on this movie thanks
when I left the film I felt like there
was so much to unpack as I was driving
home I was thinking about wounded
masculine energy how we relate to men as
women you know rich people poor people
the killing of the ego and that's why
this movie's so good because there's so
much to unpack so I wanted to know from
your Vantage Point having played James
and Gabby how are you in personally
interpreting this film
I had this a similar reaction to you
when I first read this script uh it
touches on so many interesting
um aspects of of being a human like I
said in terms of James the masculinity
uh it has that kind of
Eat the Rich uh narrative there's a
little bit of that but first and
foremost I would say the uh
the way it deals with mortality and our
fear of of death and to go on that
Journey that James goes on to be
literally confronted with your own
mortality and face to face with with
your own death to witness that to see a
clone who who is you and who retains all
your memories who believes that he is
you get executed in such a brutal way uh
what does that do to James
um
what is that uh evoke in in him and and
where do we take it from there was
really really fascinating to to explore
wow what about you Mia what was your
personal interpretation of it yeah uh
when I was reading the script it
seemed
like a really
interesting uh meditation on power
that that to me is what um was really
um coming through and especially
um the kind of the corrupting nature of
power and an even more specifically the
female corrupting nature of power I
think we you know we see so often um
what that looks like uh with male
characters but uh it's it's quite rare
to see it um with uh with uh with this
female character he also rage uh and and
and female rage in film and I think very
often it's uh rage is considered
something
um negative but I actually think it's uh
uh can be rather productive if you're
able to harness something in the way
that Gabby's able to harness the this
rage that she has with him within her
and she's able to to project that into
something that's um very cathartic for
for her and she's able to to express
these um demons that she has and she's
able to kind of you know unfortunately
really take it out on on James wow he
has so many things just popped in my
head as you were saying that I love what
you just said about rage
um and how it can be productive in the
same way that almost Envy can be a
motivator and yeah just I I was thinking
about that the whole time when when
Gabby says to James you know this woman
does what a lot of women do to men and
that is you know make them feel weak and
then to see how Gabby sort of flipped
that was just it was so interesting to
see the other side of that power coin
you have this tendency to play Such
seductive characters Mia and and I love
it so much and I wanted to know what is
the key to playing a seductive character
and and how do you personally tap into
The Art of Seduction I think thanks
seduction is something that is quite
instinctual I I you know I remember you
know actually not wanting to
really know who Alex was I didn't really
want to spend a lot of time with him I
thought it was it was um
beneficial if actually we were able to
have a bit of distance together so that
you you know we didn't actually get to
know to know each other very well I'd
heard a lot about him and and how
wonderful and and such a sweet man he is
and and if I knew that and we were to to
become friends it would have um taken
away from something you know something
you can't really explain and it's just
so I kept my distance and and that's
definitely something I I I used as a way
to kind of
to help with um the seduction I guess
wow what was it like meeting each other
then for the first time after filming it
then well I mean we did we did meet we
said hello hi nice to meet you and but
but I just kept my distance I don't even
know if you realize that but like we
they would go for dinners and things and
I didn't want to be a part of that it's
kind of did you know that Alexander uh
yeah I I knew that that was Mia's
process and and uh and I understood it
and I thought it was and I thought it
was interesting and to kind of charge
those moments in the beginning it
um I I wanted to get to know him on
camera because it was also we shot the
dinner scene when uh Mia's character
Gabby and her husband when they take it
out take us out to that Chinese
restaurant and they there's That Awkward
Moment the two couples uh try to get to
know each other that was the first day
on set which is quite
um quite nice to start with that because
we didn't really know each other very
well and
and in terms of the seduction I think it
was about James is very vulnerable in
the beginning of the movie he's very
open to being seduced because he is his
ego is is shattered he's he's got no
self-confidence and
um he's a failed writer he's desperately
trying to find inspiration but he hasn't
really found any so to meet someone who
actually looks at him and is interested
in him and and has read his book one of
the 12 people in the world who actually
read his very pretentious book the
variable Chief that's what seduction is
about getting that hook into someone
isn't it and once it's in then you got
that person and it's about that
connection and it was really uh really
exciting and thrilling to shoot that
sequence when when me as Gabby uh plays
around with with James and and hooks him
in that whole night and then when they
go to the club and there's that strong
connection and and he'll be uh eating
out of her hand from that moment on
because he's just finally someone sees
him and appreciates him or so he things
and I that sort of ties into the killing
of the ego or what I was interpreting as
the killing of the ego and I wondered
for you Alexander what was it like
you know watching your own death is such
a fascinating concept
how did that change the meaning or maybe
not of your own existence you know did
it did it alter all you think of
mortality in any way in a way it's
almost a reversal of that because I feel
like
James's Eagle was already killed or
shattered in the beginning and watching
himself
as the Clone fight for his life
on to feel that Vitality evoke something
and it it awakens something in James so
in a way
I feel that that and the way Gabby is
playing with James and starts to instill
him with confidence and awakens the ego
in a way where he almost has hubris at a
certain point in the movie and that was
a surprising twist but really exciting
to explore how did plain James help you
find meaning like in your own existence
like what were you thinking yeah it
didn't really give me any profound
answers to
to the the meaning of my existence but
it sure was a great waste of time I had
fun
it's about having fun we have uh felt
like it was well spent on set for two
months with with me and the rest of the
guys I can a thousand
from that and on the topic on uh we
actually have a surprise for you guys
oh my God no
foreign
I'm so attracted to myself right now
this is crazy I can't believe how
beautiful I am
these are clone rats I saw the whole
they made a whole body
obviously in the end of the movie We're
not gonna give anything away but
people know it's about my character gets
cloned a bunch of times so it was a
Life-Size full body version of myself
and it was very
very uncomfortable to experience that
and
slightly arousing
Neon made them for you guys cool are
they the they're from the this is the
one in the movie right the one we
actually used correct what do I do can I
like where do I put this like
hey welcome home guys come on in oh
don't mind don't mind
don't mind this one listen if I saw that
when I walked through the door I would
definitely be staying to hang out you
guys are so incredible thank you for
your time and energy take it over my bed
um
he's a good boy he's a good boy